herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem
weiteren video heute werde ich versuchen
wieder mal geld damit zu verdienen
irgendwas an leute zu verkaufen
was sie brauchen hoffentlich war das
lemonade video was vor einigen wochen
kam hat mir so viel spaß gemacht und ich
gedacht habe wie kann ich das weiter auf
die spitze treiben und ich habe die
perfekte idee dafür bekommen aber wann
habe ich die perfekte idee dafür
bekommen während ich an einer ampel
stand habe ich gesehen wie leute
angefangen haben zu jonglieren und dann
geld erfahren wollen dann ist mir
eingefallen dass morgens während des
berufsverkehrs wahrscheinlich leute
sachen bringender gebrauchen könnten als
jonglage und das waren wir uns zunutze
und werden genau in diesem moment genau
das verkaufen was alle pendler alle
leute auf dem weg zur arbeit am
dringensten bruch kaffee und essen ganz
kurz bevor es wieder losgeht vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren um keines
der folgenden videos zu verpassen
darunter auch ich habe viel aufgehängt
es wird ein absoluter traum was in den
nächsten wochen wieder für content kommt
und jetzt viel spaß mit dem video wie
auch beim letzten mal dürfen wir
natürlich keine sachen verkaufen die wir
selber gemacht haben deswegen müssen wir
uns mit einer bäckerei oder mit
irgendwem zusammentun der das für uns
macht den kaffee müssen wir geschlossen
kaufen und wir brauchen eine
verkaufsfläche wir brauchen einen
bauchladen
[Musik]
möchten sie etwas kaufen
darf ich ihnen etwas anbieten max eine
cola zero pressen oder eine mario russo
und denen das ist dann verschimmeln doch
was ja noch das ab geschmeidig mithin
vielleicht noch ein bisschen was machen
dass wir etwas umfeld und
die produkte verkaufen deswegen ruft
jetzt bei ein paar bäckereien an und
fragt ob die uns das machen können und
wie viel das kostet ja wunderbar dann
komme ich gerade vorbei ab
1 ich habe gerade auf ganz schnell welle
100 eingeschweißte brötchen mit
verschiedensten belegen für morgen 7 uhr
gestellt die ich dann auf einem
bauchladen an hungrige arbeits lustige
händler verkaufen werde und ich genau
dasselbe wieder machen wie letztes mal
das die leute selber entscheiden können
wie viel sie geben auf dem freitag
können man sich doch mal ein brötchen 55
klar natürlich
na klar ja werde größer
ich weiß was die leute
über großes glas
eigentlich wollte ich so true fruits
smoothies noch nicht verkaufen aber bei
einem einkaufspreis von 1 eur 75 pro
brötchen 12 euro smoothy kommt man ja
mit fünf euro überhaupt nicht mehr
gewinnen
vielleicht müssen wir nur bei kaffee
bleiben
kaffee brötchen zwei einkaufspreis
verkauft 5 euro 3 euro gewinnen
[Musik]
lkw-fahrer günstig machen sie das fest
ist er ist 18 euro und 20 cent haben wir
für die cafés bezahlt das ist sehr gut
und haben eine sehr hohe wenn wir denn
etwas verkaufen sollten das sortiment
wird fertig gemacht und auch die
brötchen werden mit doppelseitigem
klebeband auf meinem bauch laden
befestigt damit zum herunterfallen
guten tag darf jeden etwas zum
frühstücken anbieten auf welcher die
sachen habe ich schon unsere opfer jetzt
wo ich auch die kühltasche befüllen so
dass der kaffee natürlich auch regie wie
aus dem kühlschrank ist und dann geht's
los
lass uns da vorne auf die zur ampel
wir hatten schon alle so die wollen alle
bemüht haben und kap leben
alle wollen brötchen
jetzt heißt es über den schon
so und jetzt schaut wie der marketing
das macht hallo möchte niemals
frühstücken oder was trinken
etwas frühstücken
zeigt abgebaut direkt als auch bisher
zwei cafés pro ampelschaltung aber die
brötchen müssen hallo unserer finden
diese kind nicht mehr glauben sollen sie
auch trinken und etwas trinken
abdullah geigerin die seite haben mein
gott einer wildbrücke vielleicht haben
die getränke der bessere weg gewesen so
langsam habe ich gemerkt dass ich doch
entweder nicht die richtigen produkte
hatte oder dass meine verkaufsstrategie
morgens an der kreuzung vielleicht nicht
die richtige war
programm innerhalb von vielen schaltern
jetzt sieben euro verdient ist okay aber
es geht besser dass dinge die leute
einmal geht es überhaupt keinen bock auf
kamera aber ich habe es im gefühl es
wird besser jetzt als motto wir gut
zuzureden war scheinbar das einzige was
mich noch irgendwie helfen konnte aber
ob das funktioniert hat
das trinken trinken wie man will carmen
börse bringen ist
kostenlos weil es nicht wollen sie was
trinken
unserer franken und verschlossen sie was
trinken hier
das erste mal weg das erste break
was mich beim
die leute kaum jetzt wir haben stolz
drauf trinken oder ein brötchen ja
gesagt warum ich cool verlud ich
überzeuge mit coolness und nicht mit
produkten aber auch egal wie es ist okay
sechs ampelschaltung 17 euro nicht die
welt aber es hat zumindest in
irgendeiner weise funktioniert und wie
kommt ein bisschen was ein sonntag
und das war die nächsten fünf euro
höheren männer aber auch weil sie hören
das ist youtube wir werden wir sind
jetzt auch vielleicht schon ein bisschen
spät dran 9 uhr 30 wir vielleicht noch
einstürzen früher kommen müssen ich bin
jetzt mit drei vier stunden hier und es
passiert nichts was habe ich angenommen
vielleicht 23 euro oder so
und so langsam habe ich eine richtige
realität stelle bekommen niemand wollte
brötchen können niemand wollte brötchen
von mir kaufen und vor allem wollte
niemand brötchen wir haben die straßen
bekannt gekauft
hätte man vorher drauf kommen können
aber es war es wir hatten wir nicht so
eingeleuchtet
die dame wird auf gar keinen fall was
kaufen daher wird auch auf keinen fall
was kaufen und dieses nette ehepaar
wollte nicht nur keine brötchen kaufen
sondern auf einem business zerstören
bevor es so richtig gestaltet hat und es
hätte gestartet das ist nur eine wäre
nur eine frage der zeit gewesen habe sie
haben mir ein bein gestellt und was sie
gemacht haben sind
auch sie wollen die polen
[Musik]
euro
kostet
also mein herz
es hat nämlich schon bei dem eigenen
ich hab nämlich schon bei dem einen
gedacht der war sohn der eine dams
angeguckt hat ich schwöre der wir haben
das buchen komplett ad hoc kompletter zu
dem zeitpunkt und auch im nachhinein bin
ich mir ziemlich sicher dass dessen
hätte ehepaar die polizei angerufen hat
um mich von dort wegzukommen
aber ich glaube ich mache das nicht
weiter also es war gut ergebnis was
haben wir jetzt können gleich mal gucken
35 euro oder was nur weil ein paar ihre
männer fünfzehner gegeben haben und so
ein bisschen kleingeld aber braucht er
ja die leute haben so was von keinen
bock darauf 0,0 0,0 mein handy aber da
vergessen
also mein gott das ist umgefallen und
die oma in corner wir sind den stern
losgeworden
[Musik]
16 von sehen dass das so lange gemacht
motto alte brötchen man eine
fehlentscheidung sind vielleicht 3 oder
der luft geworden monetär was das video
jetzt kein besonders großer erfolg weil
die idee vielleicht jetzt auch keine
zehn von zehn war aber wenn uns die
brötchen gebacken sind zum nächsten
tafel gefahren und konnten damit was gut
dadurch hatten wir nichts verschwendet
die briten boden verwendet und das ist
verbessern und wenn euch das video trotz
des monetären misserfolges von 100
fallen hat dann las vegas vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren am donnerstag
kommt schon ein neues video denn hier
kommen jetzt zwei videos die bereiche
content den nämlich verfassen